欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课，先生:同学们,第二节我们来讲一下,我们如何把整个国际站整体的框架构建起来,第一个就是我们可以通过这十个关键词,就能够把整个运营的所有的内容串联起来,并且让它们之间发生具体的作用,我们所用的这个运营系统,
不仅对我们国际站有用,其他的电商平台也是一样适用的,它都是包含以下的这几个内容,第一个是店铺的内容,第二个就是产品的内容,第三个就是客户,客户这个是内容,第二个是营销,这个是数据,还有商机,订单,资金,物流,这些一个一个板块,它们都是单独存在的,它们都是这样。
在平台里面都是一个一个板块的,具体对应我们的后台呢,我们可以打开后台,针对这些板块一个一个的去学习,比如说现在是店铺板块,我们打开后台去看一下店铺的板块,你看我们的店铺板块看到没有,这个是店铺的板块,店铺板块我们可以看里面这些有什么管理公司的信息,还有什么店铺动态啊,模板啊,贸易记录这些,
商品的里面就有商品发布,管理,优品运营,这里准备升级为优品运营,行业定向争品,管理平台新品,管理认证商品,这些你看,这些都都会在这里,媒体中心就是内容,这些发布视频啊,直播视频这些都是内容,你要数据参谋就是我们刚才讲的数据板块,这里全部都是展示整个店铺的所有所有的数据,你看所有的数据,
都在这里,营销,刚才我们讲了,也就是我们所说的直动轿,问鼎,停厂,橱窗,痊愈引擎,问鼎,品牌,直达,营销连框,明星展播,这些都在这个营销里面,活动就是可能有官方的活动,也有一些我们自己设置的活动,或者是说一些营销的场景板块,场景搭配这些,还有商机,商机的话就是悬盘啊,TM啊,等等这些,在这里
可以去客户管理,关于客户的所有的信息都在这些地方,客户的营销啊,客户的分组啊,客户的分类啊都在这里,交易,交易各种订单啊,起草信保等等,各种交易数据都在这里,出口这些我们一般运营就是比较少操作的这些出口,你可以了解一下,物流的话,我们平时设置的物流板块,还有就是发货,填写物流单都是可以在这里去填写和查
查看,还有设置物流的费用板块都是在这里,资金金融一般的话,我们平时可以查一下资金,客户付款有没有到,这些都是我们运营偶偶去看的,但是具体的话,主要是公司的财务或者是负责这个板块的人去做的,下一个就是认证中心,认证中心的话就是我们的各种证书,还有店铺是精品的认证,还有其他的
实力
报告检测啊,这种都是
报告检测都是在这里,这个板块,商家成长,这里的话,主要是关于一些我们
运营的成长,或者是店铺的成长,以及一些新等级都在这个板块,那服务中心就是这些,整个品牌的一些
投诉违规啊,还有知识产权啊,还有就是那个申诉啊,还有违规的一些
频道啊,这些主要就是在这个板块,或者是说你充值了自动车,然后你的发票都是在这些地方开的
所以说,我们总结了,归纳了,就变成了这十个关键词,就能够把整个后台的运营贯穿
构建成一个你的运营系统,第一个就是店铺,第二个就是产品,第三个就是客户,第四个内容
第五个,营销,第六个数据,第七个商机,第八个订单,第九个
资金,第十个物流
是不是我们的店铺就是按照这个流程去进行一个串联的,按照这个
十个关键词去进行板块划分的,是吧
所以我们去看的时候
就按照这种思路去跟着我那个步骤去
不断的去学习各个板块的内容
这样的话你的效率会更高,就不至于你这里看一下那里看一下
最终到头来好像你
每个板块都浏览了一下,但是你不知道要看哪些内容,最终导致你学不到东西,就是这种原因
所以按照这个逻辑,按照这个顺序去详细的
去学习我们前面所说的那些
概念
板块的位置,以及一个板块之间的关联
就好了,那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
我们接着就是要开始去行动,开始去学了